this sweet green salad starts at 14.95
add avocado and it goes to 16.95
but even as it sold millions of these
bowls to customers sweetgreen has been
losing millions of dollars a month
with over 200 locations sweet green is a
fast casual restaurant trying to broaden
the fast food market to include salads
made with fresh ingredients but building
the infrastructure and Logistics to
accomplish this goal hasn't come cheap
they've always sort of branded
themselves as a tech company and so they
talked a lot about changing the food
system at one point they said that they
wanted to be the McDonald's of better
eating now they've had to translate some
of those lofty Ambitions into reality
and that's that's challenging this is
the economics of
sweet green
sweet green brought in hundreds of
millions in investment before going
public in November 2021. in an SEC
filing it reported having about 1.35
million active customers after its IPO
its stocks surge to bring the company's
value to over 6 billion dollars I'm
obsessed but its market cap has since
Fallen to almost one quarter of that
while individual sweet green locations
are profitable the company has struggled
to overcome High overhead costs in its
last quarterly report the company
announced net losses of more than 27
million dollars
the company's costs begin with its
salads
there's a few things that drive the cost
of what we do we buy really really high
quality food from Farmers we know and
trust most restaurants Source their food
through Distributors which give them
access to a wide range of food at low
prices and on top of that these
Distributors handle the transportation
Logistics
sweetgreen on the other hand Works
directly with Farms another major cost
is labor
sweetgreen has staff assembled meals and
also do a significant amount of food
prep most restaurants process their food
centrally and ship it out around the
country in order to maximize The Taste
and the freshness We Believe food should
be made closer to where the guests are
eating the food so we actually make our
food every day in a fresh in our fresh
prep kitchen Beyond restaurant level
expenses sweet green has also put a lot
of money into technology we built out
from just having a pickup channel to
building our own native delivery
partnering with some marketplaces and
even building catering and our Outpost
business we've also been able to
integrate machine learning and AI in
order to personalize a lot of the
recommendations that we give you as well
as things like our loyalty program
sweetgreen hasn't just built tech for
customers it's also built apps for
employees to plan out how much food to
make at different times of day so food
is fresh but ready when they expect
customers I would say that the founders
are trying to be more disciplined now
they've also learned a lot in stock
compensation and I think there is
certain amount of tech alignment
thinking there but you know they are
coming down to earth a bit and trying to
trim expenses where they can and be try
to become more efficient but again it's
going to take time the question is how
to do that without changing the parts of
the business that customers care about
our path to profitability in a net
income basis comes from a few lovers the
first is continuing to grow our
footprint this year we're opening about
35 new restaurants second is rowing
sales and existing stores where a huge
portion of that increase goes to lifting
the profitability of those restaurants
the third is being very disciplined on
our cost structure to make sure that the
incremental profit we're making is
flowing through the bottom line sweet
green has closed some restaurants in
cities like Boston and New York it's
also had some layoffs one of the
challenges for the business has clearly
been the pandemic and the recovery from
the pandemic in 2019 sweetgreen stores
were concentrated in urban centers but
recently it's been focused on expanding
outside cities I think we're going to
continue to build out in the markets
that we're currently operate in and
looking to open up one or two new
markets a year for the next several
years sweetgreen recently hired two
former Chipotle Executives to help make
its menu appeal to a wider range range
of customers especially as it expands
past major cities that's important
because its path to profitability
centers on having enough profitable
restaurants to offset overhead to make
each restaurant more profitable it's
also counting on increasing loyalty and
leveraging technology sweetgreen has
experimented with loyalty programs for
years and its most recent effort is
something called sweet pass there are a
few tiers in the program in the paid
version of sweetpass customers pay ten
dollars per month to get three dollars
off one salad per day
so a customer would have to spend at
least forty dollars on salads per month
to come out ahead in general restaurants
are really pushing these loyalty
programs because it makes a lot of sense
to try to get someone hooked you know
it's harder to advertise to a new
customer than it is to try to just keep
current one coming but you know if
you're going to eat that every day for
lunch that is going to add up sweetgreen
hasn't shared how many people have
signed up for its loyalty program which
it still considers a pilot another key
strategy moving forward is Automation in
2021 sweetgreen bought spice Food Co a
startup that makes automated food
assembly lines and earlier this year it
opened its first so-called infinite
Kitchen in Naperville Illinois where
salads are assembled robotically that
enabled it to hire one-third fewer staff
without sacrificing efficiency
sweet green plants continue rolling this
out to new locations and hopes to
retrofit an existing location in late
2024. probably the biggest Improvement
for our customers is much faster
throughput typically you can order your
salad and have it ready in under three
minutes even in a very busy store we
believe what this will allow us to do is
provide a superior economic model this
will significantly impact and improve
our unit economics which will allow us
to continue to scale in a profitable way
and over time may even give us some
pricing power as we think about creating
healthy food that is truly accessible
for everyone sweetgreen has made some
progress towards profitability last
quarter the company announced it was
profitable for the first time though
this comes with some qualifications
sweetgreen is only profitable based on a
measure called ebitda which excludes a
variety of costs such as taxes
acquisition costs restructuring costs
and stock based compensation it's a
measure that's popular with tech
companies but doesn't follow generally
accepted accounting principles it's a
pretty heavy list of things that aren't
included but by doing this I mean they
can say that they just had their first
profitable quarter which is in Q2 and
they want to show some progress to
investors and I think that does show a
certain magnitude of progress but it's
not all the way there the company though
is confident that it can become a
national business based on three things
it creates a new category in the market
has Capital to expand and maintains a
loyal customer base you see sweet Green
is having all three of those ingredients
as we move forward you know I think
there will continue to be challenges as
we scale whether it be how we scale our
supply chain how we scale our technology
how we scale our leadership but I think
the big thing is proving that this type
of offering can work all around the
country I think they're pretty honest
that they're trying to become a more
mature business now and you know for a
young company founded by Young Founders
that make sense that that's a little
bumpy
[Music]